THE NUMBERS ACTUALLY REMAIN
CONSTANT IN TERMS OF WHERE WE
ARE CURRENTLY APPROPRIATED AND
DR. COLLINS, OUR GREAT NIH --
>> Chris: WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
WE WILL BE POSTING THE BREAST OF
PRESIDENT'S INTERVIEW WITH THE
SECRETARY ON OUR FOX NEWS
SPECIAL REPORT WEB SITE.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS JUST
TWEETED:  I AM PLEASED TO
ANNOUNCE THAT EFFECTIVE 4/9/18,
APRIL 9TH, AMBASSADOR JOHN
BOLTON WILL BE MY NEW NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR.
I AM VERY THANKFUL FOR THE
SEVERAL OF GENERAL McMASTER, WHO
HAS DONE AN OUTSTANDING JOB, AND
WILL ALWAYS REMAIN MY FRIEND.
THERE WILL BE AN OFFICIAL
CONTACT HANDOVER ON 4/9, APRIL
9TH.
SO THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCING THAT
H.R. McMASTER, GENERAL McMASTER
IS OUT AS HIS NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR AND FORMER AMBASSADOR
JOHN BOLTON, A FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR, IS IN AS THE
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY -- LET
ME FIRST BRING IN THE PANEL,
BYRON YORK OF THE WASHINGTON
EXAMINER, SUSAN PAGE OF USA
TODAY AND JONATHAN SWAN OF
AXUOUS.
I THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY WHILE
THE TIMING MAY BE A BIT OF A
SURPRISE, THE FACT THAT McMASTER
WAS GOING TO BE OUT SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER, THE SURPRISE
AT THE TIMING OF IT.
JONATHAN, YOU'VE BEEN COVERING
THIS, AS TO WHETHER McMASTER WAS
GOING TO BE OUT, YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> I TELL YOU, THIS HAS SHOCKED
PEOPLE INSIDE THE BUILDING.
AGAIN, IT'S THE TIMING OF IT.
THERE WAS AN ASSUMPTION AT SOME
POINT HE WAS GOING TO REMOVE
H.R. McMASTER.
THEY NEVER FORTUNATELIED
THEY NEVER FORTUNATELIE
FORTUNATELIED -- FORMED A
CHEMISTRY.
HE NEVER FIGURED OUT HOW TO
BRIEF THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT IDEOLOGY.
JOHN BOLTON IS ABOUT AS HAWKISH
AS THEY COME.
THIS IS ABOUT CHEMISTRY WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
HE THINKS HE'S STRONG, HE SEES
HIM ON TELEVISION, LIKES HIM
AND, AGAIN, H.R. McMASTER NEVER
REALLY GELLED WITH THIS
PRESIDENT.
NEVER BECAME AS TOXIC AS WITH
REX TILLERSON AS THE SECRETARY
OF STATE BUT HE WAS SEEN AS A
DEAD MAN WALKING INSIDE THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Chris: I WANT TO TALK MORE
ABOUT THIS BUT GENERAL McMASTER
HAS ISSUED A STATEMENT IN
INDEPENDENCE  -- RESPONSE TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AFTER YEARS OF SERVICE, I AM
REQUESTING RETIREMENT FROM THE
ARMY THIS SUMMER.
IT HAS BEEN MY GREATEST
PRIVILEGE TO SERVE ALONGSIDE
EXTRAORDINARY SERVICE MEMBERS
AND DEDICATED CIVILIANS.
I AM THANKFUL TO PRESIDENT
DONALD J. TRUMP FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SERVE HIM AND OUR
NATION AS THE NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR.
I AM GRATEFUL FOR THE FRIENDSHIP
AND OPPORTUNITY OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY COUNCIL
WHO WORK TOGETHER TO PROVIDE THE
PRESIDENT WITH THE BEST OPTIONS
TO PROTECT AND ADVANCE OUR
NATIONAL INTERESTS.
I'M ESPECIALLY PROUD TO HAVE
WOMEN OF THE NATIONAL SECURITY
COUNCIL STAFF WHO ESTABLISHED A
STRONG FOUNDATION FOR PROTECTING
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, PROMOTING
AMERICAN PROSPERITY, ACHIEVING
PEACE THROUGH STRENGTH AND
ADVANCING AMERICAN INFLUENCE.
I KNOW THAT THESE PATRIOTS WILL
CONTINUE TO SERVE OUR PRESIDENT
AND OUR NATION WITH DISTINCTION.
BEFORE I BRING IN SUSAN AND
BYRON, JONATHAN, THE REASON I
THINK WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
SURPRISED IS THERE WAS A STORY
ON THE FRONT PAGE.
I BELIEVE IT WAS THE WASHINGTON
POST LAST WEEK THAT SAID
McMASTER WAS OUT, AND ON FRIDAY,
McMASTER AND KELLY SAID, NO,
HE'S NOT OUT, THAT HE'S THERE,
YOU KNOW, WITH THE DREADED VOTE
OF CONFIDENCE.
WHY GIVE HIM THE VOTE OF
CONFIDENCE AND LESS THAN A WEEK
LATER PULL THE RUG OUT.
>> Jonathan: THE HONEST TRUTH,
THEY DIDN'T KNOW THE TIMING.
I WAS ONE OF THOSE REPORTERS ON
THURSDAY THAT REACHED OUT TO THE
WHITE HOUSE AND THE REASON THE
WASHINGTON POST COULD RUN THE
STORY WAS THE WHITE HOUSE
STOPPED PUSHING BACK.
ON THURSDAY LAST WEEK, THE WHITE
HOUSE STOPPED LEANING INTO
AGGRESSIVELY OPPOSING REPORTERS
WHO WERE SAYING, YOU KNOW, I'M
HEARING McMASTER IS OUT.
THEY BASICALLY SAID BEHIND THE
SCENES, WE'RE NOT GOING TO WAVE
YOU OFF IN A VERY AGGRESSIVE
WAY.
THE NEXT MORNING, YOU CAN'T SAY
THE GUY IS GONE WHILE HE'S IN
THE JOB STILL.
THEY HAD TO WALK THIS VERY
TIGHTROPE KNOWING FULL WELL THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
WANTED A NEW NATIONAL SECURITY
ADVISOR, NOT KNOWING WHO THAT
PERSON WOULD BE OR WHEN HE'D
MAKE THE DECISION.
I'M TELL YOU THIS AFTERNOON, I
WAS GETTING CALLS FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE, THE PRESS TEAM WAS
CHAOTIC AND RUNNING AROUND.
IT SEEMS THEY WERE CAUGHT OFF
GUARD BY WHAT HAPPENED TODAY.
>> Chris: SUSAN, THERE ARE TWO
ASPECTS OF THIS THAT ARE
INTERESTING.
ONE OBVIOUSLY IS McMASTER, HIS
SERVICE, WHY HE DIDN'T GEL WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
APPOINTMENT OF JOHN BOLTON AND
WHAT THAT SAYS ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT'S FOREIGN POLICY GOING
FORWARD.
WE'VE GOT TO REMEMBER WE'RE LESS
THAN TWO MONTHS AWAY IF ALL GOES
AS PLANNED WITH THE SUMMIT WITH
THE PRESIDENT OF NORTH KOREA AND
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE A NEW
NATIONAL SECURITY TEAM, MIKE
POMPEO, AND A NEW NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR IN JOHN BOLTON.
WE NEED TO REMEMBER McMASTER WAS
BROUGHT IN AFTER THE PRECIPITOUS
AND SUDDEN FIRING AFTER THREE
WEEKS OF MICHAEL FLYNN AS
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR.
FIRST YOUR THOUGHTS ON McMASTER,
WHAT HE DID AND WHAT HE DID
WRONG.
>>Susan: AS YOU SAID, HE WASN'T
A GOOD FIT WITH THE PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, BOLTON WASN'T A GOOD
FIT EITHER.
BOLTON WENT IN AND MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT AND DID NOT
IMMEDIATELY CLICK WITH HIM
EITHER.
THERE'S A REASON THIS IS
SHOCKING, BUT NOT SURPRISING, WE
KNEW McMASTER WAS HAVING
TROUBLE.
IT'S SHOCKING BECAUSE OF THE
TIMING YOU MENTIONED.
THIS SPRING WE'RE SUPPOSED TO
HAVE A MEETING WITH THE NORTHERN
KOREAN LEADER.
WE MAY NOT HAVE A SECRETARY OF
STATE.
MIKE POMPEO MAY NOT BE CONFIRMED
IF THE MEETING TAKES PLACE ON
TIME.
THE NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
CAN WORK AT THE PRESIDENT'S
DISCRETION AND DOESN'T REQUIRE
CONFIRMATION.
SO HE CAN START IN APRIL AS
THEY'VE SAID.
THIS IS THE TIME WHERE WE'VE GOT
THESE HUGE FOREIGN POLICY
CHALLENGES.
WE KNOW THAT THE STATE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT STAFFED IN THE
WAY IT'S TRADITIONALLY BEEN
STAFFED UP WITH EXPERTS AND NOW
THE PRESIDENT WILL HAVE THIS NEW
TEAM THAT WILL TAKE PRESUMABLY
AT LEAST SOME TIME TO FIND THEIR
FOOTING.
>> Chris: AND AS I'M THINKING AS
YOU'RE TALKING, WE'RE ALL
OBVIOUSLY REACTING IN REAL TIME
HERE, THE PRESIDENT SURPRISED
HIS FOREIGN POLICY TEAM WHEN HE
HAD HIS PHONE CALL WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN THIS WEEK, NOT ONLY
CONGRATULATING HIM ON HIS
VICTORY BUT PERHAPS MORE
CONSEQUENTIALLY TALKING ABOUT
HAVING A MEETING IN THE
NOT-TOO-DISTANT FUTURE, AND
THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO BE IN
THE SAME CITY FOR ONE OF THESE
HUGE MULTILATERAL MEETINGS UNTIL
NEXT NOVEMBER SO CONCEIVABLY,
THEY COULD BE ON THE FLY BE
DEALING WITH A KIM JUNG UN
SUMMIT AND VLADIMIR PUTIN
SUMMIT.
>>Susan: AND WE'RE ALSO TALKING
ABOUT A TRADE WAR WITH CHINA.
>> Chris: WE DON'T KNOW IF WE
HAVE A TRADE WAR WITH THEM.
>>Susan: IT'S POSSIBLE.
IT'S A WORLD IN TURMOIL, THAT'S
FOR SURE.
>> Chris: IT IS INTERESTING,
BYRON, ABOUT JOHN BOLTON, A
RESPECTED MEMBER OF THE FOX NEWS
TEAM AS A CONTRIBUTOR, BECAUSE I
DO KNOW THE PRESIDENT WAS
CONSIDERING HIM WHEN HE FIRST
CAME IN IN DECEMBER DURING THE
TRANSITION, IN DECEMBER OF 2006
TRANSITION, IN DECEMBER OF 200
TRANSITION, IN DECEMBER OF 2016
TRANSITION, IN DECEMBER OF 2016,
AND ONE OF THE CONCERNS WAS HE
WAS VERY AGGRESSIVE, A
NEOCONSERVATIVE IN THE SENSE OF
WANTING TO CONFRONT THE
COUNTRIES AND THE PRESIDENT
WANTING TO AVOID INTERNATIONAL
ENTANGLEMENTS.
>> Byron: I THINK YOU COULD TALK
ABOUT ONE POLICY IN PARTICULAR
IN THE SENSE THAT McMASTER WAS A
GUY WHO TOLD THE PRESIDENT HE
COULDN'T DO STUFF PARTICULARLY
CONCERNING THE IRAN NUCLEAR
DEAL.
IT HAS TO BE RECERTIFIED EVERY
THREE MONTHS, SO IT'S COME UP
FOUR TIMES SO FAR, AND THE
PRESIDENT WANTS TO GET OUT OF IT
AND THEY SAY NO, YOU CAN'T DO
THAT.
MAYBE YOU SHOULD PULL OUT A
LITTLE BIT OR ISSUE AN ULTIMATUM
OR GET OTHER PEOPLE AND TRY TO
GET THEM ON BOARD.
THERE'S OTHER THINGS YOU CAN DO.
MEANWHILE, OUR COMMITMENT TO IT
STANDS.
HE SEES JOHN BOLTON ON
TELEVISION TALKING ABOUT THE
IRAN NUCLEAR DEAL, SEES JOHN
BOLTON TAKING A VERY HARD LINE
TOWARD NORTH KOREA.
HE CALLS THEM UP.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY HAVEN'T
TALKED ALL YEAR.
THEY HAVE BEEN TALKING AT
VARIOUS TIMES.
I THINK HE FEELS HE WANTS THAT
KIND OF VOICE.
ALSO, THIS IS A POSITION THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE CONFIRMED BY
THE SENATE AND GEORGE W. BUSH
WHEN HE MADE BOLTON THE U.N.
AMBASSADOR HAD TO DO IT THROUGH
RECESS APPOINTMENT BECAUSE RAND
PAUL AND OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
U.S. SENATE SAID IT WOULD NOT
HAPPEN SO IT HAD TO BE, IF YOU
WERE GOING TO APPOINT BOLTON,